5 25 now on your monday morning what's
driving you crazy extended overnight
ramp closures in the centennial bowl got
a heads up from the nevada department of
transportation as they work toward final
completion of all the work there
in 2024 okay so this week from nine at
night until five each following morning
the off ramp from the south 95 to
centennial center will be closed that's
the one that also takes you down towards
anne road and rancho and that's justin
hopkins telling us there's concrete
barrier installation and other work
going on that might also lead to
overnight lane closures in that area
this is until friday morning follow the
signs to the work zones or maybe just
skip the whole thing by using durango to
the west and jones to the east for your
southbound travel now this information
along with all our stories it's on our
eight newsnow.com website when you click
traffic and then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone something's driving you
crazy the email address traffic 8
8newsnow.com